[Musique]
le haut de la rue général de gaulle
était connu pour son ancienne caf
mais dans quelques mois c'est un grand
complexe intergénérationnel qui va voir
le jour des résidences une crèche pour
enfants considérés comme différents un
centre de bien-être et surtout un ehpad
nos seniors ont ici un nouveau lieu de
vie
quand on fait du social il faut aussi
essayer de faire bon et c'est tout un
challenge d'essayer d'être
économiquement faisable de rester dans
des coûts économiques accessible au plus
grand nombre mais tout en offrant une
prestation à la fois immobilière des
murs des belles chambres et puis une
qualité hôtelière importante parce que
je crois que c'est pas parce qu'on est
modeste qu'on n'a pas le droit à la
qualité et c'est très important ici à la
réunion ça fait partie aussi du vivre
ensemble réunionnais lequel je suis très
attaché à plus de 32 millions d'euros
investis ce groupe privé compte sur une
mixité sociale
de quoi créer une centaine d'emplois
locaux qui va contribuer à améliorer
l'offre de prise en charge et ainsi la
diversifier la moitié des logements
étant habilité par le département à
l'aide sociale
and i pad il en a besoin parce que au
fur et à mesure les personnes lâchait de
vienne
en plus dépendante et là il ya un projet
sur saint denis
mais ça n'est pas suffisant pour couvrir
tout le territoire de la réunion ont dit
qu'on est un petit caillou c'est vrai
mais dans ce petit caillou
malheureusement beaucoup de personnes
qui seraient vite et sont très
dépendants la pose d'une première pierre
plein d'émotion pour la marraine de ce
sont qui portera son nom
quand j'étais la connaissance de
marchenoir il ya quelques années que
j'ai vu ces projets où il ya comme on
l'a souligné à plusieurs reprises la
mixité sociale
ça m'a emballé ya déjà deux de fait je
vais visiter très souvent et on voit des
gens de condition très modeste avec des
gens des vip comme on dit et ça je dis
se perdre et j'ai pleuré j'ai une petite
larme
mais là je suis maquillée j'peux pas
comme tous les territoires français
le vieillissement de la population nous
oblige à construire un autre modèle où
les seniors seront considérés comme des
richesses pour notre société
[Musique]